Eddie Calif ions jewelry shop has stood
here in Athens city center for years to
his frustration jewelry is the first
thing of the shopping lists of consumers
when money is tight in recent months he
has been fighting for survival and now
this only FD virology all these taxes
raising our business tax to twenty nine
percent increasing sales tax the
measures target business owners and are
burdening us at a time when we're in a
very bad state we're all in the red and
I am too at my age it's not just
business tax that will be increased by
three percent sales tax is set for a
hike to places such as pubs and cafes
will become more expensive for customers
but will Greeks continue to buy from
these places it's a balancing act high
taxes could lead to more money in the
government's purse but it could have the
opposite effect less income if the
economy collapses the owner of this
clothing shop is anxious about her
future as holy alligator of course we
are worried about the tax increases but
what can we do there is no other
solution we must choose the lesser of
two evils what else can we do bottom of
a dragon a little mystery lava univer
the other evil would have been state
bankruptcy and an exit from the eurozone
before it comes to this many Greeks are
prepared to suffer further